i hope that she finds somebody that is
good
um and i hope that you know we get into
more of like what her dreams really are
and like
you know if she wants to sing if she
wants to dance if she wants to act i
hope that we see those
those dreams come to life nya told us
she wanted the best for her glee
character santana lopez
back in 2013. soon enough the fiery
latina lesbian would become
a fan favorite only straight i am a
straight up
that signature santana sass was somewhat
rooted in her struggle to embrace her
sexuality
i'm angry because i have all of these
feelings
feelings for you that i'm afraid of
dealing with
because i'm afraid of dealing with the
consequences those consequences included
losing her grandmother in this
incredibly heartbreaking scene
i love girls the way that i'm supposed
to feel about boys
it's just something that's always been
inside of me and i really want to share
it with you because i love you so much
everyone has secrets santana they're
called secrets for a reason
i want you to leave this house i don't
ever want to see you again
but that never stops santana from
fighting for her rights
this is such bull crap why can't
brittany and i kiss in public because
we're two girls
of course nye's beautiful voice allowed
santana to deliver
amazing performances like this cover of
fleetwood max songbird
regarded as one of her best
[Music]
and ultimately she got her happily ever
after
you may kiss one another